closures and restrictions from the
pandemic have deeply impacted businesses
including those black owned kate houston
spoke to the owner of a recently opened
mini mart
about the steps she's taken to support
and uplift the black business community
we have a lot of natural care products
for your skin for your hair
elena smith opened easy day's drive
through mini-mart on tropicana and
maryland parkway in december
on one side the mini-mart has fresh
produce coffee and food and drink items
the other side is home to dozens of
different products from local black
owned businesses
we thought it would be a good idea to
offer them a space where they can
have an actual storefront and people can
come here buy their products
learn about their products and they can
build their name at the same time that
we build
ours the urban chamber of commerce says
black owned businesses were hit hard
during the pandemic
with many not able to fall back on
savings or borrow funds to stay afloat
joe kato a board member with the chamber
says having local businesses support
each other will be essential moving
forward
it means that we have to circulate the
dollars in our community
that is something that we should be
doing and circulate those dollars to
make sure those businesses stay
open and they are successful so
i'm all for recycling the black dollars
by highlighting products and clothing
from black owned businesses
smith hopes the money will be put back
into the community
we can take that money and put it into
schools that will help our children as
far as education
we can put it into better health care
for our people we can put it into
helping us get
housing and counseling smith now hopes
to build a small kitchen inside the
store to offer a place for black owned
food establishments to prep
and sell their items kate houston 8 news
now
very smart ideas there will